[Música]
en las américas café el programa aquí le
ofrece el servicio en español de radio
canadá cada semana con estas preciosas
imágenes que estamos viendo de distintos
puntos de canadá montreal toronto y lo
este las rocallosas paisajes que yo
conozco es parte no todos aunque hay que
y hay gente que ha viajado mucho
convenciones para los barrios pero
estuvimos juntos en la roca y estas
cosas efectivamente ya muchos años
tenemos que darnos otro viaje yo lo más
lejos que fui fue a long
de frente al nuestro
estamos los gays y no les crea en el
tiro les damos la bienvenida a todos
ustedes a través de los diversos canales
de comunicación que tenemos ya los
conocen por un lado en nuestro sitio en
internet www rs y net punto sea
nuestro canal de youtube que es cada
semana más consultado por nuestros
públicos nuestros oyentes es decir
escuchas rededor escuchadores
youtube la aplicación que ya también
pueden consultar que mucha gente ya ha
bajado y está consultando semana a
semana a través de los diversos
dispositivos móviles como los teléfonos
las tabletas como las que tenemos aquí
para que nos puedan seguir las 24 horas
del día donde ustedes se encuentren con
todo el material del que dispone en
nuestro sitio internet que es muchísimo
los reportajes entrevistas mucho
material fotográfico notas de tecnología
como las que produce cada semana
leonardo y precisamente estamos aquí
presentes hoy en este estudio pablo
gómez barrios bienvenido un además
pablos muchas gracias y bienvenidos a
todos allá leonardo gimeno que tal
buenas tardes buenas tardes del mundo
buenas tardes o lo que sea bueno buenos
días y cuando lo esté mirando por
ejemplo
como siempre efectivamente mi nombre es
luis laborda y hoy además tenemos una
invitada una colega del servicio en
francés de la radio en francés de radio
canadá marie france ha bastado que
participa de la emisión de shot el lema
exactamente una de las variaciones más
importantes que tiene la radio en
francés en pocos instantes vamos a estar
hablando con ella sobre un trabajo muy
importante que han hecho allí en la
emisión de des hotel sobre méxico
mensah que también tiene las facetas de
la vida en méxico y por supuesto de la
relación entre méxico y canadá pero
antes de pasar al diálogo con ella
quería decirles como siempre a que nos
sigan a través de nuestro sitio en
internet que tendrán allí dos temas
musicales que me agregaremos en esta
ocasión son dos temas que es son
interpretados por dos mujeres
sarah mclachlan por un lado
y por otra parte bueno dos temas
musicales en nuestro sitio en internet
que podrán entonces seguir quienes vayan
así al sitio internet porque nuestra
televisión y éxito
[Risas]
para mirarnos
ese es el precio de la fama bueno pero
más allá de los chistes que hacemos
siempre en cada apertura de nuestra
emisión hoy es una fecha muy importante
a nivel mundial porque se cumplen 25
años de la llegada al poder de nelson
mandela hace 25 años nelson mandela
ganaba la presidencia en sudáfrica a la
presidencia de su país se convertía
entonces en el primer presidente negro
resultado después del apartheid en esa
nación tan castigada por la segregación
racial ponía de esa manera un broche de
oro a una etapa oscura la historia de
ese país
y se convertía como decíamos entonces en
el primer presidente negro sudafricano
las imágenes que ustedes están viendo
son imágenes grabadas en canadá cuando
vino de 93-95
no estoy seguro del año en que fueron
tomadas esas imágenes pero él agradece
en esa participación que estamos viendo
allí el rol que jugó canadá en ayudar a
su país a recuperar por un lado la
democracia plena y por otro lado bueno a
combatir y a poner fin a la segregación
racial a la dominación que llevaba
adelante la minoría blanca en esa nación
que no dejaba ocupar ningún cargo
electivo no dejaba ocupar ningún cargo
de valor a ningún nivel ni político ni
comercial y de ningún tipo a la enorme
mayoría de población negra sudáfrica si
a países puede después de muchos años de
y su liberación cabe señalar aquí que
fue el fruto de una campaña
internacional en todo el mundo se decía
liberen a mandela liberen a mandela y
canadá efectivamente jugó un rol
importante en ese proceso porque fue uno
de los líderes de esa campaña
internacional también y así que se hizo
presente aquí y agradeció en ese
discurso que estamos viendo al pueblo
canadiense y al gobierno canadiense de
ese momento el rol jugado por ambos para
ayudar a que sudáfrica pudiese dar
vuelta a la página y poner fin entonces
a la segregación racial nelson mandela
que se convirtió entonces en presidente
en el primer presidente negro
sudafricano el 10 de mayo de 1995
y un poco triste dentro de esta historia
es que bueno estaba leyendo algo a ese
respecto últimamente donde decía que no
hay que decir que todavía muchos
problemas en sudáfrica y se decía que
aún las tierras pertenecen a los blancos
en sudáfrica así de que esa revolución
que hubo finalmente pues fue un fuego de
paja como dicen en francés porque 27
años más tarde los sudafricanos siguen
todavía sufriendo de segregación si
entre ellos mismos saben es en la
actualidad de la formación política y
social en sudáfrica dista de ser las
mejores las maneras
digamos que se ha avanzado bastante
respecto de lo que era ese país hace
unas décadas atrás y el hecho de que
nelson mandela fuese primero liberado
luego de haber pasado décadas confinados
y luego pudiese encarar una carrera
política llegando a ser presidente de su
país
y claro yo estuve en áfrica del sur en
johannesburgo en particular en el año
2001 más o menos y recuerdo un accidente
no lo voy a explicar pero tuve que ir al
hospital y en ese momento traía
solamente mi documento bueno mi
pasaporte mexicano porque todavía no
tenía mi pasaporte canadiense y al
llegar al hospital pues no tenía seguro
y el pasaporte no lo vieron nada rápido
no lo vieron más que rápidamente pero
muy yo sentía al llegar a ese hospital
que había mucha discriminación y el
color de mi piel no es blanco pero
tampoco soy y soy en negra entonces me
veían como porque en ese momento
johannesburgo era una ciudad en la que
llegaban muchos inmigrantes del norte de
áfrica entonces de entrada primero
pensaron que yo era un inmigrante ilegal
y después dieron el pasaporte después me
atendieron pero digamos que la
segregación yo la sentí incluso en el
ambiente hospitalario porque había como
más que segregación como desconfianza
desconfianza de lo que es distinto y
creo que eso
probablemente es una cuestión muy humana
también lo que no conocemos no tenemos
confianza necesariamente inmediatamente
y eso se seguía viviendo cuando yo
estuve segregación que además fue la
pólvora de una violencia generalizada un
crimen en que se cometían y que de
alguna manera se cometen a uno hoy pero
mucha menor escala en la calle a la
plena luz del día yo el único recuerdo
que tengo de sudáfrica me ganas en eso
yo me hago personalmente pero sigue
sobrevolando el territorio sudafricano y
he quedado hasta el día de hoy hace
muchos años lo mismo curiosa experiencia
impresionados lo que son los paisajes de
sudáfrica visto desde el aire
del suelo también sé exactamente
entonces nuestro homenaje al hoy extinto
nelson mandela que fue entonces el uno
de los iconos de la lucha sudafricana
por la igualdad de razas y que se
convirtió como decíamos en el primer
presidente negro de esa nación
y vamos a comenzar a dialogar entonces
todos con nuestra invitada de hoy
deseamos marie france ha bastado que
forma parte del equipo de míchel de
shuttle en el programa es hotel en imax
que se emite todos los domingos por la
radio en francés de radio canadá a
partir del mes de marzo comenzaron a
poner en el aire una serie de contenidos
un trabajo muy extenso muy amplio con
diversas facetas que han realizado
respecto del méxico que nos puedes
comentar marie france and white vector
es una serie de reportajes de terreno y
de entrevistas hechas por nuestro
animador demichelis hotel y mi colega
michelle labbé y quisimos tratar de
entender un poco más ese país que todos
pensamos conocer por lo menos aquí en
canadá no conocemos su comida sus playas
conocemos lo que conocemos un poco
porque es nuestro socio en el tratado de
libre intercambio
y al final no lo conocemos tan bien y
quisimos profundizar ese conocimiento en
el marco en el contexto de la llegada al
poder de andrés manuel lópez obrador
después de 70 años casi sin interrupción
del del poder del pri del partido
revolucionario institucional y bueno
quisimos ver un poco de de qué se
trataban esas toda esa esperanza de que
qué era eso de que eran las esperanzas
del pueblo mexicano
con ese nuevo gobierno sobre todo que
habló hizo muchísimas promesas una de la
más importante prometió una cuarta
transformación del país nos refiriéndose
a la primera que era la independencia la
segunda que era la reforma en la segunda
mitad del siglo 19 y luego a la
revolución mexicana al principio del
siglo 20 y bueno aparte digamos más
precisamente prometió poner fin a la
corrupción y la impunidad y prometió
tratar de asegurar una mejor
distribución de la riqueza por ejemplo
como un gesto simbólico cuando llegó al
poder por todo bajo los salarios de
todos los altos funcionarios
algo que no debió gustar mucho un poco
mi puesto por supuesto que ya que tuvo
mucho descontento con esa política con
esta medida también prometió mejorar la
seguridad una promesa muy
es importante sabiendo que en 2018 fue
el récord de homicidios en méxico 30.000
homicidios en 2018 y por fin
prometió promover el desarrollo
económico a través de megaproyectos
ahora antes de entrar en detalle en el
material que como decíamos es muy
diverso muy amplio nos mandaste el
vínculo hacia la página de internet
donde se encuentra todo el material y
realmente muchísimo lo que hay para ver
ahí lo está mostrando nuestro técnico y
amigo pierre ni tilde
como cómo hicieron para me gustaría que
antes de meternos en el tema en sí mismo
nos contaras un poco cómo hicieron el
trabajo de hecho cómo hicieron para
producir tanto material como visión para
producir tantas entrevistas tanto
material fotográfico como definieron el
recorte y cómo se organizaron mira hay
que serlo con poco para hacer para hacer
eso pero decirte cómo todo se construyó
es un poco difícil porque bueno partimos
de lo que leemos de nuestros intereses
personales adentro del equipo
y poco a poco se va formando una especie
de corpus de los reportajes que queremos
hacer de las entrevistas que queremos
hacer y luego hay que ver lo que se
puede hacer porque hay que llamar y ver
que se que se puede concretar
exactamente entonces y para lo que es o
sea que los temas se definieron un poco
a poco pero por lo que se trata de mirar
yo estuve hice lo mismo para mi colega
michelle la wta que yo estuve doce días
en mexico y volví con el material para
siete reportajes que es una locura la
verdad es una locura porque estamos
trabajando todo el tiempo todo el tiempo
sin parar pero no sé creo que es una
cuestión de pasión y de una vez que
estamos allí como vamos no vamos a
menudo como desgraciadamente méxico no
está muy cubierto aquí bueno una vez que
estamos allí que queremos aprovechar y
bueno
y tu pensamiento tu visión personal no
solamente como periodista y luego de
esos 12 días de estar en méxico con todo
ese material producido de qué manera se
modificó
ay
qué bueno sabíamos y si yo sabía por
supuesto que amlo tenía un desafío los
retos increíbles
pero pero volviendo de allá te preguntas
realmente cómo lo va a hacer eso primero
porque porque es con tan grande hay hay
tantas cosas que cambiar en méxico la
corrupción está tan metida en todos los
niveles de la sociedad
la inseguridad y la inseguridad es
increíble si todo el mundo
sabes que cuando vamos al extranjero así
trabajamos con fixer con píxeles
y yo trabajé con dos estuve en oaxaca
estuvo en chiapas y los dos me hablaban
pero todos estamos en el auto todo el
día viajando juntos y te hablan entre
muertos de asesinos de miedo de miedo y
yo no quería tener solamente esa esa
visión negativa de méxico porque méxico
es mucho más que eso es un país con una
cultura increíble es un país que vibra
que se desarrolla que o sea pero pero
eso está muy muy presente y la otra cosa
la impresión que me quedo es que
yo pensaba que la mayoría de la gente
por supuesto no los priístas no los
panistas pero que mucha gente estaban
detrás de él lo que es el caso pero hay
muchas críticas también hay gente
crítica por ejemplo yo que vi que no
pensaba que iba a ser tanto yo pensaba
por ejemplo que los indígenas luego los
indígenas sobre los cuales trabajé
bastante
y van a iban a estar más confiados en
hambre y no es para nada lo que lo que
vi ni lo que es tiene muchas reservas
muchas muchas si con ellos no yo estoy
es yo estuve echándole un vistazo a todo
el material que ustedes están
presentando escuché varias de las
entrevistas y me parece que cubrieron en
verdaderamente en gran medida lo que yo
escucho de la gente con la que hablo el
contacto que yo tengo con mi familia con
mis amigos con colegas de trabajo que
tengo allá también entonces creo que
está muy bien hecho el material porque
justamente representa esa es a ese
horizonte tan vasto y tan complejo que
significa méxico que tiene que tiene
méxico hoy y los desafíos como como
dices marie france que tiene el
presidente pero que también tiene la
gente al intentar entender la manera en
que el presidente quiere llevar a cabo
todos esos proyectos porque mucha gente
se pregunta por qué está tomando esa
decisión es porque le falta experiencia
es porque realmente sabe para dónde va
hay mucha inseguridad la gente tiene
miedo de que no funcione el proyecto y
que solamente tiene seis años para
implantarlo y la presencia del crimen
organizado la presencia de la corrupción
dentro de los diferentes niveles como
decías de la sociedad del gobierno de
las instituciones incluso privadas es
tan grande que cómo va a poder llegar
digo únicamente a hablar de la gasolina
lo que hizo con la gasolina querer sacar
al crimen organizado de la del robo y la
distribución de gasolina mexicana lo
comenzó al principio de su sexenio y
hasta el momento no logra solucionar es
muy complejo entonces yo creo que él
el conjunto de los reportajes que fueron
hechos por los colegas de radio canadá
en francés representan bien lo que yo
escucho y lo que yo he visto en méxico
recientemente la parte cultural también
que está cubierta que me pareció muy
interesante también descubrir estuve
también como paloma echándole un vistazo
a
los reportajes que ustedes hicieron para
ver que habían cubierto
por supuesto excepto los artículos en el
web pero somos antes de todo
reporteros de radio trabajamos tanto en
hacer vivir no así los lugares con el
sonido y todo por eso siempre digo yo
que si no tienes tiempo puedes leer pero
porque se trabaja mucho lo que es
también hacer reportajes y todo el
trabajo que nos lleva y efectivamente
escuchar los reportajes nos da otra
visión de lo que se está haciendo no sé
y el punto de los indígenas esto estos
grupos rock indígena no que cantan en
sus lenguas somos fantásticos son
buenísimos sin pantallas es buenísimo yo
después de haber hecho el reportaje
escuché y escuché una y otra vez sus
músicas son muy buenos y por qué hacer
el rock
porque hace un reportaje sobre los
jóvenes que sandro que en méxico no era
sobre el rock era sobre el boom del rock
indígena o sea realmente es que se hace
en otro tipo de música también la rap
hip hop o qué sé yo pero pero es que los
pioneros fueron un poco esos rockeros de
chapas uno en particular
damián guadalupe del grupo zac civil y
fue realmente bueno primero eran jóvenes
les gustaba el rock y cuando empezaron a
componer canciones y escribir canciones
dijeron y porque lo voy a hacer en
español porque lo voy a hacer en
castellano mi idioma en este caso por
ejemplo es el show seal entonces lo voy
a escribir en sutil y no fue tan bien
recibido al principio ni de ni de los
mexicanos no indígenas ni siquiera de
los indígenas de los de los pueblos que
decían que es eso y están vendiendo
la cultura y están tratando de pero con
el tiempo hicieron su uso un camino y
uno de los ejes que abordaron es el tema
de la inmigración que es un tema
complicado de por sí que ha sido página
la primera página de la mayoría de los
medios impresos y ha cubierto horas y
horas de la radio la televisión de todo
el mundo sobre todo a partir de los
roces que se han producido por el tema
inmigratorio entre básicamente entre
méxico y eeuu que no puedes decir al
respecto bueno es que yo quería ver a
una de las promesas que hizo amlo
durante la campaña electoral fue decir
vamos a dejar de tratar los migrantes
tan mal como lo hemos hecho hasta hasta
ese momento vamos a tratar no de
deportarlos
pero vamos a tratar de protegerlos
porque se sabe que hay digamos si los
abusos son los abusos son increíbles el
narcotráfico y las bandas criminales
bueno hacen mucho trata de la trata de
personas de personas etcétera
prometió eso pero en la realidad yo
estuve yo estuve en la frontera sur
en tapachula en una ciudad fronteriza en
chapas para ver que si hay buenas
intenciones pero pero no hay los medios
por ejemplo en el reportaje hablo de eso
no dicen que van a dar
los títulos de que van a otorgar más
títulos de refugiados pero cuando vas
ahí te das cuenta que no hay filas hay
gente que duermen en frente del no me
acuerdo cómo se llama el instituto de
omar creo que tomar la forma de la
comisión de ayuda a refugiarse y hay
gente que duerme ahí sin diez días para
tener eso y la verdad es que esos mismos
organismos no sólo no tienen el personal
para atender esos esos migrantes pero
además hay hay mucha corrupción hay que
cambiar las cosas hay que cambiar las
mentalidades de la gente de la coma
de la gente del otro el instituto
nacional de migración hay tanto que
hacer hay tanto que hacer y no y además
entre las buenas intenciones que puede
tener el ejecutivo es sí y las presiones
de eeuu
hay un margen no sé no hay siempre
coherencia entre el discurso y lo que se
puede hacer y lo que se puede hacer
bueno ya sabemos que el camino que lleva
al infierno está asfaltado de buenas
intencionados en méxico como en otras
partes antes de continuar el diálogo con
marie france yo quería saber si tenemos
algunos mensajes que hayan llegado a
través de esos sitios en internet y si
tenemos aquí mensajes y dice e ismael
zamora 10 y saludos necesario a tierra
de guanajuato méxico y celebrando el día
de la madre hay un montón de países que
celebran hoy el día un montón
gilberto martínez saludos desde
nicaragua manuel escamilla saludos desde
campeche méxico césar rodríguez jarr y
saludos desde colombia y miriam alarcón
hola desde argentina son las personas
que están en este momento conectadas con
nosotros en nuestra red social viendo en
directo este programa pues nos saludamos
a todos ellos y le agradecemos como
siempre estar siguiendo no sé
acompañándonos en cada emisión que
hacemos aquí cada viernes desde este
estudio que estoy relativamente flamante
flamantes rescataste cuando comenzamos a
hablar el tema de la cultura y de que
méxico tiene una vasta y muy extensa y
muy antigua pero al mismo tiempo
renovada también cultura que se va
regenerando continuamente que puedes
decir lo que hicieron ustedes respecto
de ese
y bueno estoy mirando a mi mis hojas
porque son temas sobre los cuales
trabajo trabajaron mis colegas pero una
cosa muy interesante es una entrevista
que hizo michelle de sotelo con el
politólogo ricardo raphael que habla de
cultura como un poco un reflejo de las
desigualdades de la sociedad mexicana
pero también nos habla de las de la
increíble riqueza de esa cultura
milenaria y de la efervescencia cultural
increíble que hay en mexico en todas las
áreas nombre desde pintura de música de
teatro de literatura y le hablo eso me
parece interesante porque era un
fenómeno que yo no había medido de la
influencia increíble que tiene todo ese
todo ese tránsito fronterizo pero ahora
hablo de la frontera del norte
ese tránsito que hay entre mexicano
quedan eeuu que regresan y todo eso como
eso marca ha marcado muchísimo la
cultura de esos últimos años y por otra
parte también hay michelle la break que
hizo un reportaje sobre la ciudad de
méxico no una ciudad tan tan vibrante
tan donde bueno pues eso la cultura es
increíble que es facilísimo entender a
la cultura si hay sol hay de todo y es
casi gratis y eso lo iba a decir
y lo hace hace un recorrido con gente
que viven en méxico
con gente que también con extranjeros
que adoptaron la ciudad y que que hablan
de porque hay gente por ejemplo que
llegaron allí para seis meses y que
están todavía después de 17 años y que
hablan de ese amor que tienen para
conozco uno repasó eso argentina y
después viajó para aquí se quedó algunos
meses y aquí está
[Risas]
[Música]
y por supuesto de marie france uno de
los temas que hay que abordar aunque sea
someramente porque no sé si es
específicamente lo que tú trabajaste es
la relación que existe entre méxico y
canadá que se ha visto también
modificada y fuertemente en los últimos
tiempos ese tema también está dentro
sobre ese tema hay un reportaje de mi
colega michelle la break él fue a
querétaro es muy interesante porque
quiere talos se volvió un pueblo luce se
dice eso en español trial aeronáutico
después de la llegada del boom de el
torno de los años 2000 y hoy en día hay
no menos de 80 empresas en s
en ese campo
y bueno eso es muy interesante yo hacer
minería y yo hablé si es totalmente otra
otra cosa otra perspectiva de la
presencia de las mineras canadienses en
méxico del impacto que tienen sobre las
comunidades por supuesto no hable de
todas las mineras fui a en un pueblo en
el estado de oaxaca para en el pueblo de
san josé del progreso para mostrar un
poco como como bueno la población está
totalmente dividida entre los que están
a favor porque porque si se viven de
ello pero y también porque se ve que el
el pueblo vive de eso sé que el pueblo
dinero es más dinero entras en el pueblo
y las calles son pavimentadas y estás en
el estado del más uno de los más pobres
de méxico y hay una iglesia inmensa que
se está construyendo construyendo hay un
mercado así rutilante
se ve pero también hubo tensiones hubo
violencia
hay tiroteos en la noche porque tratan
de intimidar a la gente que no está no
está a favor en en fin
así que si tocamos ese tema también que
y lo que es interesante es que no creo
que no creo que cambie mucho las cosas
durante el mandato de de amlo porque
ahora mismo a principio de marzo en
toronto un méxico mining day quiere a un
día para atraer ese méxico venía a hacer
ese méxico mining de aquí en pronto para
atraer inversiones mineras o sea que la
minería sigue siendo así un sector de la
economía sobre la cual cuentan muchos
igual es complicado porque ese tipo de
cosas vienen hace muchísimos años y en
un mandato o dos mandatos quizás el
tiempo no da para corregir
una historia bien ósea lamentablemente
todos los niveles que están dentro de
esa telaraña que soporta a la minería no
van a desaparecer porque una persona
tenga el impulso y las ganas de hacerlo
se necesita realmente una cosa
extrema para poder arrancar de raíz no
arrancar pero por lo menos que encontrar
el sax una alternativa que sea viable
para los dos lados lo mismo sucede en
que en canadá en las zonas petroleras de
canadá la gente depende desde de esa
industria por muy contaminante y muy
cuestionada y controvertida que sea
entonces de qué manera puedes crear otro
otros caminos para que la gente para que
los jóvenes encuentren trabajo a largo
plazo es lo mismo que se siente porque
desarrollan expertise particulares
habíamos prometido 10 minutos hace 22 o
[Música]
me pregunto cómo hace alguien de aquí
para mantener una lengua extranjera
cuando uno que hace ya años que vivió
aquí le cuesta mucho todavía el día de
hoy expresar en su lengua también de
alguna
mira si no sé por qué adopte ese idioma
como mi segundo idioma no es el inglés
el español creo que hice pero subió
estudiante formalmente lo estudie
formalmente pero también estuve viviendo
en algunos países en argentina
por eso recordamos nuestro público
entonces que todo ese material del que
vos no venís hablando y mucho más y
mucho más está en la página internet de
la emisión del hotel leriba cns y pueden
acceder a él en cualquier momento pero
quiero precisar que es la página hay una
página principalmente si sobre sobre eso
sobre esta serie es que se llama
méxico colonia méxico entre luz y sombra
que hay que agregarle también a nuestros
oyentes o escuchar es que y que está en
francés
desafío
[Risas]
muchísimas gracias por haber estado
presente aquí bienvenida y las puertas
están abiertas para cuando gustes el
placer es enorme y no muchas veces
solemos hacer este acercamiento entre un
sector y otro de radio que nadal
deberíamos hacerlo más a menudo así que
bueno bienvenida y me gusta las puertas
están abiertas si quieres por supuesto
puedes permanecer aquí estamos
el programa nada más vamos a hacer
algunos mensajes de nuestros oyentes
porque a veces nos olvidamos de dar
respuesta a los muchísimos mensajes que
nos llegan antes de presentar nuestros
temas de la semana quién quiere comenzar
a leer alguno de los que yo tengo aquí
una preparado primer ministro de alberta
adquiere 40 mil inmigrantes que deseen
establecerse en zonas rurales y luis
garay nos escribe un mensaje dice que
los requisitos
tengo que tener para poder aplicar y
poder ir a canadá cuál sería el
procedimiento y que expiden para ese
proceso muchas gracias
habría que entrar al sitio de la
provincia de alberta para ver
efectivamente cuáles son los requisitos
para este tipo de procesos paloma y
sobre el tema médico canadiense dice que
la diabetes tipo 2 es curable mari dice
y respecto a la neuropatía a las
neuropatías diabéticas porque hace una
pregunta desaparecen si se registra en
normalización de funcionamiento del
páncreas
y no sabemos pero lo que sabemos es que
la información probablemente se
encuentra en el reportaje que me
gustaría responder a la brevedad si al
controlarse el azúcar en sangre las
neuropatías diabéticas son reversibles o
no yo tengo una teoría y no soy médico
pero yo supongo que sí a partir de la
diabetes una pérdida de visión por
ejemplo la visión no se recupera
también porque el daño en el ojo ya está
causado igual que en el caso de
amputación de algún miembro o la mal
función de otro órgano que esté ligado
ciertamente a la mal función del
páncreas supongo que no que no no no hay
retroceso lo que esté lastimado entre
comillas queda atrás timados pero lo
importante que no se siga estimando y
que provoquen un desencadenado brutal de
la historia
si una pregunta muy simple que nos hace
lily anal con respecto
noticia que nosotros publicamos
universidad canadiense investiga cultura
espacial de los astronautas en el cosmos
ella se pregunta y cuál es la definición
de cultura espacial yo también me la
pregunta debe estar en el reportaje y
por el momento no tenemos la respuesta
pero efectivamente en qué consiste la
cultura espacial sabemos qué bueno si
podemos llamar esa cultura espacial hay
un astronauta que de que se que se
encuentra en este momento en las
estaciones pero más allá de poco cuando
antes de darle paso a paloma para que
nos presente el tema que uno de los
temas que trabajó durante esta semana
quiero agradecerle a rafael reyes plaza
sendas cartas que nos hizo llegar a
través del correo postal
ordinario y adivinen de dónde vienen de
cuna
de cuba queremos agradecerle a las dos
cartas que nos ha hecho llegar que
atesoramos entre los diversos mensajes
que recibimos continuamente de todos
nuestros oyentes dentro de nuestro
público en general mejor dicho paloma de
todos los temas que trabajas que esta
semana cuál es el que privilegia hace
que recomendadas al público para que
accedan primero el caso la historia del
wiimote que es el primer partero de la
provincia de québec el primer hombre que
hace partería que practica la partería
en que ve que es muy mal t y hay un
documental que se llama que se llama aún
todavía un hombre partera y así se dice
porque en francés hay que decirlo las
personas que practican la partería
hombres o mujeres se llaman sus fans y
su familia tiene incluida la palabra fan
que es mujer
entonces la traducción literal del
título del reportaje es el hombre parte
pero parte de eso esté explicado porque
hasta ahora eran siempre mujeres
que puse ahí porque justamente explica
la historia de este hombre y explica un
poco el documental como tal es un
documental de marketing offline
entonces los invito a que vayan a ver
ese reportaje porque van a entender un
poco el contexto en el que se desarrolla
este joven cartero el primero que cuando
el pse se registró para hacer la carrera
eso causó revuelo sí porque además toda
la descripción sobre la partería en que
ve que estaba feminizada lo cual es raro
porque generalmente uno masculiniza todo
para simplificarlo pero en el caso de la
partería todo estaba en mujer entonces
ya la comadrona la estudiante labrador
era mientras que él era hombre dice a lo
mejor me aceptan y finalmente si lo
aceptaron el primero pero ahora va a
cambiar todo la descripción y de haber
cambiado
sugerido tema sugerido es una entrevista
que hice esta semana con joan sebastian
rulli que es el director y curador de la
muestra que ve cine en méxico entonces
se está llevando a cabo termina el 12 de
mayo que comenzó el 2 y termina el 12 de
mayo esta muestra de cine que este año
está quinta muestra está dedicada a una
parte a los 80 años a la celebración de
los 80 años de las visas de la oficina
de la oficina nacional de películas de
canadá a la o ene efe y por otro pero
por otra parte se le dedica al cine de
animación entonces de hecho el nombre es
de mclaren es un homenaje también entre
otros a mclaren a norman mclaren que es
uno de los pioneros del cine de
animación aquí en canadá y en quebec en
particular de mclaren al 3d entonces hay
71 películas
en el marco de este festival todas
películas de animación en la ciudad de
mexico en la cineteca nacional de méxico
entonces si se presentan entre otras dos
películas de frederic bag que es el
hombre que plantaba árboles que trabajó
y que ganó un oscar y cientas por acá en
el corredor en el pasillo entonces un
crack dos películas de frederic va que
entonces pues es una entrevista
interesante que podemos escuchar en
nuestro sitio
rcn punto sea sí señor bueno antes de
los saludos a miriam alarcón dice que
dirección de email puedo enviar un vídeo
de la zona en la que vivo gracias
bueno mira ahí te mandamos la dirección
de vídeo sino que lo ponga directamente
en la página de facebook nosotros
recuperamos el vídeo y hay otro súper
fan me encanta esto que ponen súper fan
gustavo lucas y se salud desde melón un
carro de cerro largo
o varios viernes que no me conectaba
decían llegó de una reunión de la
comisión de fomento de la escuela en
algunos países las llaman las
cooperadoras así que bienvenido gustavo
que de gustavo y lucas son los nombres
de las gracias gustavo y aquí seguimos
que en este caso con la conversión
tecnológica google y trevor project
juntos para combatir suicidios en los
jóvenes usando inteligencia artificial
trevor project es un proyecto nació a
partir de un cortometraje ganador de un
oscar en el año 1991 en el 94 abrieron
cuando se iba a pasar por televisión
este de este trevor project este metro
porque era el cortometraje hicieron una
línea para ayudar a los jóvenes con
problemas que tienen que ver con la
la comunidad de jóvenes en eeuu y en
este caso lo que hizo fue se presentó
este tramo project a un llamado a un
concurso de google para un premio eran
20 que se elegían 20 proyectos para
ayudar a los demás y en este caso exacto
traigo el proyecto ganó y su línea y su
página internet y su y todos los
recursos con 50 trevor project van a
estar ahora apoyados por la tecnología
de la inteligencia artificial eguro y tú
para nada yo tengo un reportaje pero no
lo vamos a presentar porque no queda
demasiado poco tiempo habló camina un
material tuyo que queríamos presentar
sobre una iglesia que filma en las
inmediaciones del canal para los que no
sepan hay dos iglesias en frente de
radio canadá de las cuales una que está
en un estado lamentable eso lo vamos a
dejar para la semana próxima para poder
presentar más con más calma con más
tranquilidad darle el espacio que se
merece como cada semana siempre
pensamos que podemos poner montones de
materiales en nuestra experiencia de
programa lo mismo creemos que no
llegamos a cubrir el tiempo y después
nos faltan todo el tiempo para respetar
todo lo que tenemos así que le damos
nuestras gracias al público una vez más
por acompañarnos como cada semana
gustavo me dice aclaración gustavo es mi
nombre es lucas es mi apellido
entonces por molestar un poquito gracias
una vez más a marie france ha pactado
gracias a paloma donarlo a pablo ya
todos ustedes hasta la semana y al
técnico de todas las transmisiones hasta
la próxima chau adiós sigan bien
[Música]